so da bin ich am start
gachi buzz ich muss gerade auch schnell was zu trinken holen deswegen bin ich
bisschen außer pust ich bin gerade übelst die treppe hoch gesprintet also sofern mir
sofern ich das also jetzt ihr dürft jetzt euch nicht das so wahnsinnig schnell
vorstellen aber ich meine mit 38 mit ja mit max max max 36 oder wie alt bin ich
jetzt 36 ja ich kann mir das nicht mehr merken mittlerweile ich bringe das total
durch an mann mann sage ich 34 was eigentlich 38 irgendwie ist das random
heißt so um den eigentliche eigentliche datum rum was ist denn blitz wolf
alter ja genau den china smoke detector genau den den
wüsste ich mir bestellen so sieht es aus da kann man sich dann richtig drauf
verlassen auf den china raucherkenner
so haben wir wieder zu und musik ist ein bisschen laut weil ein bisschen leiser
wub wub wub das ist auch so nerviges wub wub wub ich brauche irgendwie ich
brauche nicht so nerviges wub wub wub okay das dudelt jedes mal okay
wir können es an mix und dann suchen wir einfach die letzte woche und gut ist
nicht jeder irgendwie irgendwie kram hoch
das ist doch alles das gleiche immer das hatten wir schon 20 mal
das ist immer der gleiche schütt klauen die alle voneinander
klauen die alle voneinander oder hört sich das einfach alles extrem gleich an
was schon das headset mit kühlung gesehen was was headset kühlung
warum frost cap
das ist aber schon ja alt warum warum brauchen ein headset aktive kühlung das
ist doch das ist doch irgendwas wo man es wieder besser aussehen möchte besser
aussehen lassen möchte als es eigentlich ist
ich finde wenn ich so also wenn ich kopfhörer in dieser optik schon sehe
habe ich schon wieder kein bock
warum brauchen die die kühlung ich verstehe es immer noch nicht so genau
frost cap
was letztendlich steckt hinter diesem begriff der platier element effekt dass
die eine seite kalt wird die andere seite warm oder ne ne ist das nicht dass
es ab einer gewissen temperatur sich biegt okay zu smart bei dem thermo
elektrischen element abdeckung des lautsprechers durch in der hörung
okay okay das wird außen warm und dann wird es innen kalt wird auf der eins
also sprich das sind dann kopfhörer die an den oren kühlen die idee finde ich
gar nicht mal so doof ich war man könnte einfach dafür sorgen dass sie ordentlich
gelüftet durchlüftet sind aber man kann sie auch kühlen
dass im gehen sie die für den kälte effekt ein gel also sprich dass es so eine
mini klimaanlage im headset
ich finde eigentlich die idee gar nicht mal so schlecht ehrlich gesagt das ding
sieht halt so plastik mäßig aus aber die idee finde ich gar nicht übel das
problem was ich bei solchen herzsatz nur immer hab ist dass die zwar coole
ideen haben aber in der hauptdisziplin meistens übelst abkacken im vergleich
zu halt stink normalem audio equipment
ich finde die idee nicht schlecht muss ich jetzt mal ehrlich sagen also ich
finde ich finde ich die idee finde ich gut ob es was taugt ist halt die große
frage die bewertungen sind so eher und ich meine was haben wir für bewertungen
haben wir mal ein paar geizhals wie heißt das ding hp omen was kosten da
spaß überhaupt dass das also wenn das ein ordentliches headset ist also wir
gehen jetzt mal davon aus es wäre also wenn wir mal von ausgehen würden das
hätte ordentlichen sound dann ist der preis vollkommen ok aber wahrscheinlich
ist das sound so wie so ein billig logitech kopfhörer und das kostet so
viel weil es kühlung hat hast du heute versucht in xbox zu bekommen
ne habe ich nicht das was ich versuchen werde ist in moment wann ist das ich
habe es mir aufgeschrieben 24 übermorgen bin ich hier am start
24 9 bin ich hier am start und gucke ob ich mir rtx 3090 kaufen kann ich sollte
mich so ich sollte mir einen click bot programmieren wisst ihr wisst ihr wie
viel uhr das freigeschaltet wird um wie viel uhr ab 15 uhr da bin ich noch auf
der aber da könnte ich einfach wie verrückt klickern
der stuhl mit kühlung was gibt auch ein stuhl mit kühlung ok 15 uhr 15 uhr
wann ist das 15 ne moment moment 24 ist das freitag donnerstag
ich hoffe wir können bis dahin wieder home office machen das werden viel einfacher
aber das sieht billig aus irgendwie und die bewertung ist es irgendwie teurer
geworden wie gesagt das headset finde ich von der
idee eigentlich ganz cool wäre es nicht besser auf die customs zu warten
naja ich habe jetzt glaube ich die letzten drei grafikkarten alle
referenzdesign gehabt
ich habe damit jetzt keine großartige probleme gehabt ein paar grad kühler sind
wahrscheinlich die custom karten aber ich glaube nicht dass ich das da
großartig und
also ganz ehrlich die idee finde ich gut aber ich glaube nicht dass das dass ich
mir irgendwie sowas kaufen würde also wenn ich mir wieder mal ein headset
kaufen würde dann würde ich mir höchstens eine neue eine neue version vom
mx 300 kaufen irgendwie davon in eine neue variante
was auch die man die hier am start haben was der team geier ach nee der team
tiger das fangen die auch schon mit so komischen namen ist das die günstige
variante vom mx 300
das ist auch eine variante mod mix habe ich auch noch zwei stück oder ein paar
das gibt ja mittlerweile auch ein paar andere so eine handvoll halbwegs
brauchbarer entsatz wie man sich holen kann
choose my name mal wenn ich muss man den chat hier muss man chat auf machen
choose my name sagt gerade bei uns kacken alle kacken alle surfer ab im
rechenzentrum und der max der muss erst mal grafikkarte kaufen
man muss prioritäten setzen ja also lebt man um zu arbeiten oder arbeiten
mann um zu leben das ist die frage und die nächste frage die man sich dann
stellen muss gehört die grafikkarte zum leben dazu
ich gebe so extrem philosophische fragen die hier mit die man sich heute abend
stellen sagen das ist schon hart am an hrq dran ja und ich würde sagen ja
macht sie weil eine grafikkarte ist wichtig dass man dann in seiner freie
zeit ordentliche sachen am pc machen kann aber ich muss sagen dass mod mick
das mod mick ist eine gute gute
sache wenn man schon gescheiten kopfhörer hat also was am mod mick gut
ist also ich meine das ding hier allerdings sind die mittlerweile abartig
teuer die neue variante will ich mir gar nicht mehr kaufen davon die über
3 ist mit dem preis voll exzellent somersprossen
guck mal hier die wollen sie die haben sie nämlich alle mittlerweile die sind
vollkommen vollkommen gestört ich gebe doch keine 120 doch noch mal zusätzlich
fürs mod mick aus so
der kopfhörer frame sieht mir ganz stark nach einem senheiser hd 800 aus
wo ich war so gestört war und wollte mir welche holen aber habe ich zum glück
nicht gemacht mod mick usb ist trotzdem ganz schön teuer geworden der kram
früher hat das um die genau genau früher hat es um den dreh gekostet eher
noch ein bisschen noch ein bisschen günstiger also von der idee her sind die
mod micks cool ja aber ein anständiges usb mikrofon kannst du nicht ans
zeitzeit pappen am 24 915 nur gibt es die 30 90 3090 so also weil jetzt ich muss
jetzt mal eine sache fertig fertig erzählen und zwar ich habe ja zwei mod
micks die dinger sind eine ganz gute idee die funktionieren auch ganz gut
allerdings muss ich sagen dass mx 300 mikro ist besser
ja und man hat genau das kommt auch noch dazu man hat zwei kabel aber das lässt
sich eigentlich ganz gut managen man kann das einfach um das andere kabel
drum herum wickeln das problem ist die dinger sind mittlerweile viel zu teuer
geworden das hat man früher um die 35 euro gekostet
dann war das noch ganz brauchbar ja also ich habe ich habe die ich habe die nicht
die neueste generation mod mix aber zwei davor ausprobieren ich muss sagen ich
finde das mx 300 mikro klingt viel besser das klingt die alten klang so ein
bisschen badewanne bisschen rau nach rauer badewanne kann man jetzt kann man
jetzt schwer beschreiben das mx 300 für finde ich mikrofon da hört man sich
relativ neutral an wohingegen beim mx 300 der kopfhörer auch eher badewanne bass
aber die eher bass badewanne ist so viel dazu also ich finde die dinger nicht
verkehrt dass der riesen vorteil an diesen dinger ist man kann sie halt mit
jedem x beliebigen kopfhörer zusammen machen also mit jedem x beliebig
kopfhörer paaren also wenn jetzt einer wirklich so verrückt ist und hat so ein
ultra teures 1000 euro kopfhörer und das möchte er unbedingt zum spielen und im
ts labern öfter ts lull ts in 2020 discord labern verwenden dann ist so ein
mod mit gar nicht mal übel ich habe allerdings schon ein paar audio puristen gehört die sagen
das geht ja gar nicht dass das wort mich per magnet hier dran befestigt wird meiner
meinung nach totaler blutsinn das ist jetzt so wirklich kein großartig starker magnet
musik ist zu laut so hallo zusammen wie wird denn das mod mit an den kopfhörer
gepappt das zeige ich dir das besteht aus zwei teilen einem teil mit kleber dran ich
hoffe man kann das hier sehen und einem teil mit magnet dran die zeigen mir aber
lieber eine brücke anstatt wie ihr herz hat funktioniert das ist ja auch massiv
high IQ und mal shop
das mal gucken ob es hier zeigen also hier siehst du es ja ungefähr kann man das bild
mal verkrörelte alle rechtsklick bildschutz was ist mit euch was ist mit
euch kaputt
ja da sieht man es du kriegst einmal so ein ding zum an zum dran pappen und dann
am mikrofon selbst so ein magnet du kannst das mikrofon nach hinten und
vorne schieben das kann man so aufdrehen da kannst du das mikrofon ein bisschen
weiter nach hinten machen ein bisschen weiter nach vorne machen die durch und
das die kann man glaube ich auch nach bestellen diese dinger also du kannst
alle deine 5000 euro kopfhörer mit so einem so einem ding ausstatten und dann
kannst du einfach überall das mod mit mod mit dran packen ist eigentlich eine
gute idee ich fand es nicht so schön
ich fand es nicht so schön ich hätte eine andere lösung besser gefunden weil
man kann das nicht stufenlos verstellen
das kann man kann das nicht stufenlos verstellen man kann das halt immer nur
von einer ecke auf die andere stellen was meiner ansicht nach nicht fein
genug ist
ja save was eben unter der so wirklich alternative dazu gibt es halt nicht die
sache ist halt dass es das also ich denke das richtet sich hauptsächlich an
leute die schon richtig gute teure kopfhörer haben und auch durchaus mal
was im nicht im bereich von 100 200 euro sondern vielleicht sogar im bereich
45 600 euro vielleicht sogar 1000 euro und wenn man dann wirklich damit spielen
will wenn man die sachen schon hat ich meine warum nicht warum nicht ich meine
schlechter schlechter ist das auch dadurch ja jetzt nicht im game nur weil
die kopfhörer teuer sind das bietet sich dann schon an also mal angenommen mal
angenommen ich hätte irgendwie sowas hier angenommen ich hätte mir irgendwie
sowas mal gekauft was ich nicht was ich preisleistungsmäßig komplett
beknackt finde also mal angenommen ich hätte mal so immer angenommen ich hätte
so kopfhörer ja ganz ehrlich da würde ich mir auch ein mod mit kaufen dass ich
mit dem ding spielen kann gibt ja noch mehr so teure gibt gibt bis 3000 4000
euro und also kopfhörer ist auch open end letztendlich ja wenn ich sowas
also wenn ich so einen kopfhörer hätte dann würde ich mir garantiert auch einen
mod mit kaufen man muss halt sagen preismäßig ist das halt echt also das
kann doch so gut sein das ist glaube ich eher was für leute die
halt gerne sagen möchten so ich habe so das letzte quäntchen dings an audio
qualität so und
eigentlich brauchen tut was nicht ich glaube das ist noch nicht mal was für
apple user dafür sieht das nicht stylish genug aus also für apple user
müsste das noch ein bisschen bisschen abgedrehter aus bisschen bisschen kühler
abgedrehter und und apple apple liga aussehen dafür allerdings kannst du dir
auch schon für 1600 euro top ausgestattetes neues das iphone kaufen
dann machen apple leute eher das
jede das lohnt sich das als meine meine ansicht es gibt ja noch mehr es gibt ja
noch vorn ich habe vergessen wie die heißen von sony hat auch so teure dann
gibt es gibt es gibt auch eine reihe ich habe mich jetzt schon zwei jahre nicht
mehr großartig damit beschäftigt es gibt eine richtige high end kopfhörer
szene so die sich dann auch untereinander austauschen auf reddit in voren so nach
dem motto ok was hast du heute gekauft ich habe mir mal neues für 3000 euro probe
gehört ja was doch ganz nett vielleicht hole ich mir wo die einen sich
irgendwelche golden bmw kaufen kaufen sich irgendwie andere leute zu viel geld
haben und auf audio equipment stehen kaufen sich 5000 euro kopfhörer
also da gibt es schon da gibt es schon es gibt schon ein paar richtig gute
sachen aber ich bin da mal es lohnt sich nicht so viel geld dafür auszugeben so
kommen wir zu eigentlichen eigentlich sag ich muss das mal amson aufmachen
genauso die die ja hast du recht jontron genauso welche zum beispiel und du
kaufst die 30 90 naja man muss sagen es ist ähnlich es ist ähnlich aber der
unterschied von einem goldenen bmw und 5000 euro kopfhörer ist dass die nicht
in dem verhältnis besser sind wie es eine 30 90 rtx ist natürlich ist das
well natürlich geht das value runter also für du kriegst für den doppelten
preis oder für den dreifachen preis natürlich nicht die dreifache leistung
sondern vielleicht 15 prozent mehr wenn du glück hast aber das ist schon mal ganz
andere eine ganz andere nummer und außerdem reden wir da auch von ganz
anderen preisklassen ja aber es geht nicht das geht schon in die
gleiche richtung hast du recht also preisleistungsmäßig ist natürlich eine
30 90 rtx auch nichts auf der anderen seite darf man nicht vergessen
ich habe ja auch gar nicht voll großartig meine grafikkarte zu upgraden
also ich habe jetzt die 1080 ti die habe ich drinne seit kann das ziemlich
genau sagen da hatte ich sie schon ich habe ihr wollen ich habe ich die so
habe ich gar ein video dazu machen müssen damals ja so ungefähr seit mitte
juli 2017 habe ich die bekomme heute lull ich habe märz
ok exakt also ich weiß dass ihr seitdem ich die grafikkarte habe ich twitter ja
bei jedem blödsinn also drei jahre ungefähr und da kann man das schon mal
machen sich alle drei jahren ordentliche grafikkarte kaufen
ist gar nicht so alt nö aber für eine grafikkarte ist es alt ich meine guck
mal das sind dreieinhalb jahre ungefähr ziemlich genau dreieinhalb jahre
dreieinhalb jahre für eine grafikkarte ist eine enorm lange zeit an so einem
kopfhörer hast du länger also wenn man angenommen jemand ist wirklich so
hart drauf und kauft sich in 3000 euro kopfhörer da hast du definitiv länger
dran als andere grafikkarte und 3,5 jahre sind für eine grafikkarte schon ziemlich
lang so aber kommen wir mal kommen wir zu eigentlichen einkauf action also ich
habe ich habe wie immer ein paar sachen mir aufgeschrieben die ich wo ich mal
gucken will was es so gibt und was ich mir holen will ob wir da alles finden sei
mal dahingestellt so und das erste was ich gesehen habe auf amazon ist folgendes
vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere noch an meinen stream
china steckdosen leiste flaschen monka smoke
nix also wir haben eine china steckdosen leiste geflasht
drei drei stück glaube ich drei china steckdosen leisten haben wir
geflasht und zwar die hier
ja die hier haben wir damals geflasht lokale arttp seite mit api ja ich kann
ich kann es euch mal zeigen wie es aussieht
das war kurz in mich gehen das müsste irgendwas 100 101 102 excellent ich meine
ip adressen aus wenn ich weiß so sieht das ganze jetzt aus web interface hier
kann man einen ausschalten knopf 1 bis 4 sind die steckdosen 1 bis 4 und 5 ist
die usb was schau dir mal den razor sealer an was ist das denn razor bin ich
kein fan von was denn das
ein gaming router so was darfst du mir nicht schicken
so was darfst du mir nicht schicken da bin ich wieder jetzt eine halbe stunde
dabei mir das anzugucken und mich drüber zu beschweren was mir nicht
gefällt ok zeigt man ja was was kann was was was kann das denn also razor sealer
gaming mesh router was also mal ehrlich die leute die sich so was kaufen die
spielen doch über kabel aber egal multichannel 0 weight ok dfs das hat mit
fußball nichts zu tun oder ist dfs irgendeine qo sq geschichte ja ja ja ja
das ist was anderes ist was anderes dfs ist für kanalwahl ist das automatische
channel aus automatisches channel auswählen keine ahnung habe ich noch
nie gehört wenn man alle abkürzungen kann man wirklich auch nicht kennen
dynamic frequencies ach ja das ist automatisches auswählen der frequenz
ok das können aber auch deutlich günstige kisten schon so also die ganzen
wlan geschichten sind erstmal wurscht für wirklich für wirklich gaming weil
kaum einer spielt über wlan der sich so was kauft hybrid wireless mesh razor
fast track adeptik was moment mal was für dinge razor das muss ich mir jetzt
angucken was das ist so razor fast track adaptive traffic avoidance
die will das ding an traffic avoiden wenn das spiel was verschicken will da
willst du was verschicken und beck howl channel für ein selbst optimierendes
also ich muss jetzt mal dazu sagen wenn ich das so durchlese ja also ich arbeite
in dem bereich seit ungefähr 2007 ich bin jetzt zwar nicht im netzwerkbereich
also ich bin jetzt nicht der ultra netzwerk pro ja aber ich habe keinen
blassen schimmer was das ist ich habe wirklich keine ahnung hat block blockchain
fehlt mit blockchain moin cheesy pro 36 v2 hast du einen neuen account
so also gucken wir mal weiter was das ding hat multikan als 0 dfs latenzfreies
gaming und streaming dank multikan als 0 wenn ich glaube die die machen
buzzword buzzword die droppen einfach die buzzwords
also nein es sind nicht mal buzzwords die tropfen einfach die die big brain
words ohne jetzt irgendwie erklären was es denn wirklich ist also gut das ding
wählt automatisch den besten channel aus das ist jetzt für gaming nur so am
rande relevant also gut hybrid wireless mesh ist für gaming auch egal weil
keiner spielt über wlan der wirklich ordentlich spielen will
razor faststrike der razor faststrike priorisiert also ganz normal qs mit
presets ja gut das ist jetzt wirklich nichts besonderes es kann sogar eine
fritzbox das heißt schon was adaptive traffic avoidance und schwarm
intelligenz schwarm intelligenz alles klar das ist okay den wird echt nicht so
blöd adaptive traffic avoidance kennt auf intelligente art und weise mehrere
kanäle um einen zu finden der frei von staus ist und der cloud basierte
lernende algoritmus der schwarm intelligenz merkt sich im handtuch drehen
welche frequenz ist zu meinen jetzt ernsthaft dafür braucht man ei wozu
braucht man da ei also ich mein hier oben okay also der router guckt einfach
welches wlan frequenzen nicht nicht so belegt sind und dann sucht er sich eine
raus die halt freier ist als die anderen so und wozu brauche ich da jetzt cloud
ai sind mit kanälen ruten gemeinten ne wehlaan wehlaan kanäle also channels
wehlaan channels meinen die damit würde ich mal würde ich jetzt mal vermuten
weil die hier was von frequenzen schreiben
aktiv aktiv steering warum sind die eigentlich alle so geil auf
wehlaan niemand spielt über wehlaan der der ordentlich spielen will also die
also alle wehlaan features sind komplett useless
voice video others gaming aha mich ich muss ich muss gucken was da für eine was
ist denn da für eine cpu drinnen zeig mal her ich muss mal gucken was da drinnen
steckt was sie da ob man das rausbekommt was sie da drinnen haben
ich muss ich muss da jetzt mal bei denen wie gesagt sowas dürft ihr mit
sonst dürft ihr mir nicht schicken ich muss ich muss gucken was da was da für
eine da für eine cpu drinnen ist
was ist das für was das hier für kommet musik im hintergrund was da ist
ein link zum datenblatt drinne hier das zahl neben amazon meiste
warum ist die musik jetzt auf russisch datenblatt ach hier guck mal
das ist das hässliche datenblatt für so einen teuren router den ich je
gesehen habe aber gut das ist ja nur wirklich jetzt kein kein ding also das
darf meinetwegen hässlich sein alles in ordnung als ok guck mal wpa 3 könnten
wir heute schon mal machen
wpa 3 ist ja so der neueste shit gibt es ja schon gibt es ja schon die ersten
paar dinger unter anderem irgendwelche china also wenn ich das ding im keller
stehen hätte da würde ich mich jedes mal erschrecken weil ich denke in
riesen spinne sitzt an der wand so wifi 6 genau so zeug das könnte man schon
machen das ist das ist relativ standard was
hatten die was ist da für eine cpu drin guck mal für den preis für den preis
wäre auch einen gigabit oder zumindest zumindest ein was vollkommen irrelevant
ist das sind alles stinknormale 45 stärker also für den preis wäre
zumindest 2,5 g oder in 5 g anschluss noch drin gewesen oder also man bekommt
nichts was du mit einem router mit usb 3 anfangen
kannst wahrscheinlich kannst du usb stick dran stöpsel und so und so billig nass
der billig nass ist damit machen gut es muss mir nicht weiter angucken ist
glaube ich ziemlich ja dem ich ja blödsinn
da in der ecke ist das also drinne ok
ok dass ich schwachsinn das braucht kein mensch
ist das ein dsl router
ja also die rgb beleuchtung sollte da eigentlich schon auch drinne sein kann
die fragen ja das tut weh also kann der router meinen ping am pc stabil halten
wenn andere geräte im wlan oder lagen gerade videos schauen ok ok die die frage
ist tatsächlich ist ich dachte es kommt eine blödere frage die frage ist
tatsächlich nicht blöd allerdings wird icmp meistens standardmäßig nicht
priorisiert aber man weiß ja nie was da eingestellt ist
was hat denn p was hat denn was hat denn upnp damit zu tun dass der ping von ihm
stabil bleibt da antworten da antworten die profis den voll profis so wie es
aussieht
das ist das ist massif pains camp ja kann er natürlich kommt es auf die
einschätzung an die kannst du ja mit dem moment das ding hat eine app man muss
das über eine app steuern
ich selbst finde super aber du musst nicht etwas auskennen bei deinem router
eine pnp das ist eines der ersten features die ich weil immer ausschalte
na gut ok man kann sich viel einreden wenn der tag lang ist für wlan mag es
vielleicht was taugen keine ahnung aber jemand der ernsthaft spielt spielt
nicht über wlan und irgendjemand hat noch gesagt ich soll danach suchen das ding kenne ich das ist
das unify ding habe ich aber nicht ausprobiert die sieht halt ein bisschen
aus wie das sieht ein bisschen aus wie wie dieser eine robot aus wall-e die
haben einfach nur die haben die haben einfach nur irgendwelche technischen
begriffe gedroppt ok es ist bescheuert braucht man echt nicht so also ich gucke
jetzt mal kurz in chat weil ich wieder bestimmt ein paar sachen übersehen
habe gibt es einen grund warum du deine iot sachen über wlan steuerst du
über sie wo sie ich mache beides ich habe das meiste zeug was wenig strom
verbrauchen soll ich sie wave ich habe kein sick wie bei mir also zum beispiel
die open close sensor fürs fenster also solche dinger sie wave kein door sensor
so dinger hier also ich habe nicht die teuren hier ich habe auch aliexpress am
start bei aliexpress kriegst du teilweise zehn stück für den preis und die sind
jetzt nach zwei jahren das erste mal leer deswegen muss ich auch ein paar
batterien verkaufen viel zu teuer also sowas sowas sowas dürft ihr auf gar
keinen fall bei amazon kaufen da geht er geht auf bengot wartet auf ein
guten gutes angebot sagt sie wave door sensor oder sowas und und dann sieht man
ist sie aktuell viel viel zu teuer an sich kaufen vielleicht sind das auch
schon mehrere wie viele sind das einer viel zu teuer also ich habe mal elf elf
dollar bezahlt die habe ich nämlich das sind nämlich die ich die genau die habe
ich genau die habe ich und ich habe elf dollar das stück bezahlt und ich habe
noch genug es war gerade ein angebot auch bei bengut elf dollar stück
das kann man sich kaufen 35 euro überlegt luxusmarke ist klar überlegt
euch mal window überlegt euch mal 35 dollar für eine für ein fenster oder
eine tür da wirst ja armen guck hier 10 10 euro zwelle alles klar australien
polen china australien polen china china ist am billigsten o china
ab wann geht der preis hoch direkt o aliexpress leckt heute aber ganz schön
aliexpress standard shipping
was für den los
also das kann man sich dann schon eher eher kaufen aber aber 35 euro pro pro
sensor ist viel zu teuer ja die die schaumy aquara dinger sind auch ganz gut das aber
sich wie glaube hat die ps5 eigentlich auch den router eingebaut
also wie gesagt mein zeug besteht zum größten teil aus sieben mit mit mit
wählern sachen dabei er zusätzlich ich muss kann man kurz durch den chat
scrollen dass ich nichts übersehen habe also ich habe viele nachrichten nicht
gesehen bekommen auch nicht dass ich selbst übersehen habe
glaube nicht
ab das beider nämlich dt 77 pro ja das ist auch nicht übel das ist ja quasi das gleiche was
auch im mx 300 ist ok
glaube ich habe alles glaube ich habe nichts übersehen gut also kommen wir zu
eigentlichen zur eigentlichen sache die ich eben eigentlich schon schon sagen
wollte und zwar ja die sind gut die sind wirklich gut die haben die habe da habe
ich auch zwei stück von zwar ich habe einmal so ein das ist der erste den ich
mir gekauft habe und jetzt einen und jetzt noch so ein beste beste weder an
ex des points die es gibt ich kann aber jeden verstehen er sagt ich will keine
100 plus euro für den ex des point ausgehen euch steht mir ein und ich habe
auch in den raspberry pile dran der das ganze managt
ja die sind wirklich gut kannst du sein oder je nass empfehlen ich habe keins aber
wenn man einfach nass will anschalten und geht da sind die dinger zu gebrauchen
ja es ist nicht so dass ich sagen würde auf den finger weg kann man schon vor
allem wenn man keinen bock hat selbst großartig was zu machen sind die dinger
gar nicht so schlecht die ex des points benötigen auch einen router für die
reine ex des points geschichte natürlich nicht aber wenn du was machen
möchtest daheim brauchst du also du brauchst ja immer einen router wenn du
von einem heimnetzwerk irgendwie ins internet willst also irgendeiner muss
muss das ja also irgendein netzwerkgerät muss das ja machen
was ist denn das wo man ein bisschen was machen muss
in den low power in low power intel board zum beispiel so was hier mit vier
sata anschlüssen und dann selbst machen
mehr oder weniger so sachen sind in sein knowledge die dinger auch drin also
ungefähr von der leistungsfähigkeit ja aber sagen wir so die sind sogar noch
ein bisschen leistungsfähiger was hältst du von power line adapter kann man
machen wenn gar nichts anderes wenn gar nichts anderes geht kann man power line
verwenden ich finde ja wlan an sich nicht verkehrt
wlan ist schlecht ist besser als ein ruf finde ich also ich würde wahrscheinlich
erstmal wlan probieren bevor ich mit power line rumwurste das beste ist
natürlich bleibt ist und bleibt kabel und oftmals hat man noch ein paar trete
irgendwo liegen und kann doch ein kabel liegen oder kann da doch ein kabel
draus machen aber wenn es gar nicht anders geht bleibt
ja nichts bleibt er nicht viel übrig
nee der unify controller macht weder dhcp noch nadt noch sonst was der
controller ist wirklich nur dafür da deine ex das der controller ist quasi
das web interface für deine access points es gibt unify geräte die du mit dem
controller steuern kannst die nadt dhcp routing geschichten machen aber der
controller selbst macht das nicht ganz ehrlich ich würde auch nicht wollen
dass der raspberry pi sowas macht viel zu lahm das teil dafür lieber weh mal
zwei mal wie lieber wlan zweimal extenten oder power das kann man nicht
sagen das hängt vom gebäude ab wlan wlan repeater sind an sich meistens nicht
so tolle
ja das ist schwer zu sagen das hängt das kann man echt nicht so pauschal sagen
so aber wir müssen jetzt mal langsam zum zum zum einkaufen kommen und zwar wie
gesagt ihr erkennt ja noch die die den stream den ich gemacht habe mit mit
der steckdosenleiste so das war die hier und ich war letztens auf amazon und hat
mir gedacht hey guckst du mal guckst du mal es ist schon die hier oben empfohlen
wird guckst du mal ob es wieder neue china steckdosenleisten gibt also ich
habe damals dafür bezahlt ich gucke mal kurz nach muss man kurz nach gucken
co geek waren und bestellung co geek ich habe dafür bezahlt 29 euro 89 und das
ist auch nicht shoppen für weihnachten so und mir ist jetzt aufgefallen dass ich
noch mal so zwei drei gebrauchen könnte zum beispiel einmal für den keller bei
mir im schlafzimmer und dort wo mein 3d drucker steht
deswegen habe ich mal bei amazon geguckt und mir ist aufgefallen dass es original
die gleiche steckdosenleiste noch mal gibt jetzt allerdings nicht von co geek
sondern von von mehrers also keine ahnung was mehrers ist aber das ist ja
alles china resale also ich also ich zeigst euch mal ich habe die hier gekauft
die da für 28 29 euro und ihr werdet sehen guckt euch mal an guckt euch das
bild von der an co geek und guckt euch das bild von der an und hat schon
gewisse ähnlichkeiten oder die powerline adapter haben doch nichts mit
wlan zu tun nein haben sie gar nicht null ich was ich sagen wollte ist dass
wlan oftmals besser ist als sein ruf also ich würde es erst mit wlan
probieren bevor ich es mit powerline probiere also das ist original die
gleiche steckdosenleiste so und ich habe überlegt ob ich mir nicht noch mal mal
zum testen erst mal eins bestell und gucke ob man die noch flaschen kann was
kann man damit machen du bekommst also standardmäßig würde ich die nicht
verwenden man kann die flaschen mit einer custom
firmware und dann hat man sowas dann bekommt man ein webinterface
worüber man die steckdosenleiste steuern kann remote also man bekommt quasi für
und das ist amazon preis also wenn man das bei aliexpress bestellt ist
wahrscheinlich noch billiger wobei ich elektronik krams was ich an an
230 volt anschließt ungeheim irgendwie bei aliexpress kaufe was eigentlich
eigentlich bescheuert ist weil im prinzip ist das ja auch aliexpress
kaufst du mir ein august 260 was ist das überhaupt für die kamera was august
260 pass auf jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich in so ein händel kissen oder so
ach so das ist ein kabeltester oder sowas ah das ist nice die teile sind
sind sind sind sind huge das ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht so ganz billig was
kosten so ein teil
ach nur drei nur 3000 euro da kann ich mir auch einen kopfhörer verkauft
ups ich wollte ich gar nicht anklicken gerade falsch
ne wollte ich wirklich eigentlich ja die dinger sind wirklich nice also ich hatte
noch nie ein aber 3000 euro ist mir für netzwerk tester auch ein bisschen zu
viel
so zumindest habe ich überlegt ich kaufe mir davon mal keine ahnung jetzt
erstmal erstmal eins zum testen guck ich habe mir ein kopfhörer verkauft
zum testen guck da können wir im stream wieder gucken ob sich das noch flaschen
lässt weil das coole daran ist also vergisst diese vergisst vergesst diese
komische china ab die tun jetzt war so so nach dem oder man kann es über
alexa streuen google assistant smarts in fernpil alles für den arsch braucht
kein mensch das beste ist die dinger flaschen mit custom firmware und dann
kriegt man so ein webinterface für die steckdosen leiste und kann die benutzt
jemand überhaupt smarts ins jetzt war das war das das samsung ding dann
wahrscheinlich irgendwelche unwissenden casual noobs ja bestimmt bestimmt so
und das gute daran ist man bekommt quasi für 34 euro eine ip steckdose
34 euro für eine ip steckdose ist ziemlich gut
was sebaro was ist das das ist ein video zu einem kabel tester ok image film ok
das ist nur eine minute weil es da sebaro ist gucken wir uns das jetzt an
berührungen sorgen für veränderungen bringen prozesse ins rollen
verbinden präzisionen mit leidenschaft berührungen geben den takt vor und
erzielen den gewünschten erfolg
die wollen mir nicht wirklich erzählen man kann auf dem kabel test der youtube
gucken oder
wollen die mir wirklich sagen man kann auf dem kabel tester youtube gucken ja
ich meine das hier ist e 3d render da können die mir alles zeigen youtube auf
dem kabel tester da brauche ich kein smartphone mehr da kaufe ich mir jetzt
nur noch machen alles im kabel tester 260 der all in one broadband tester ist
der erste agus mit touch display das produkt design für den robusten
arbeitseinsatz vereint intuitive bedienung mit gewohnter agus menüführung
er verfügt über alle erforderlichen breitband schnitt stellen was haben die
mit ihrem touch testet und viele weitere schnitt stellen die alle technologien
einschließen inklusive eingebautem koppermodul
entwickelt für umfassende testforderungen der agus 260
wtf
was kann man damit sich alles angucken und ip tv youtube die wollen es aber
echt wissen hier der agus 260 ist durch die modulare sfp
schnitt stelle für zukünftige technologien gerüstet
testet weitere extra ist das testen noch effizienter der agus 260 touch
generation kann man kann sich youtube angucken auf dem kabel tester das hat
schon was das hat das hat was
im prinzip ist da innen drin wahrscheinlich in den android oder so
touch it testet
touch it testet das kriegt man wieder nicht aus dem kopf
okay also so warum habe ich so viel sachen im wahrenkorb liegen
das ist noch vom letzten mal erst mal löschen erst mal löschen nicht da ich
zu viel kaufe ist auch vom letzten mal drinnen
was kupon aktivieren spars spa abo ich will kein spa aber für eine steckdosen
leiste wie darf ich mir das vorstellen kriege ich dann jeden jeden monat eine
neue steckdosen leiste geschickt oder fast
touch it testet klicken sie auf dem button kupon aktivieren bei geeignet
und klicken sie dann auf artikel anzeigen auf die kupon okay
ich bin sogar zu dumm für den kupon einzulösen
ach hier ach nee ich muss mich anmelden dafür okay exzellent
gilt das für jede steckdosen leiste oder nur einmalig
nur noch heute ja das gilt morgen auch noch
ich probiere mal kurz nebenbei im anderen browser da wo ich angemeldet
bin aus wie das ist mit kupon einlösen so in den einkaufswagen wagen legen ich
muss es gerade mal nebenbei ausprobieren
kupon aktiviert kann ich das jetzt noch mal
ah nee das geht nur für eine das geht nur für eine steckdosen leiste
okay leute ich bestell mir mal kurz nebenbei auf dem zweiten rechner ein
und dann probieren wir aus ob man das ganze flaschen kann irgendwann am
wochenende oder so 28 99 sehr gut exakt so viel wie kogik wie die kogik steckdosen
leiste gekostet hat lieferung donnerstag 24 september
exzellent gratis amazon day moment wann ist was ist was ist was ist amazon day
gratis amazon day
hä ja aber einmal so der ist doch noch gar nicht am 13 oktober
ok keine ahnung was was die da wollen ich sage gratis versandt bis 24 september
alles gut das ist übermorgen jetzt kaufen sehr gut exzellent so das probieren wir
dann aus am wochenende oder so ob sich das flaschen lässt so also es kam die
frage was man damit macht beziehungsweise was das bringt jetzt muss
ich jetzt mal ganz kurz darauf eingehen weil ich verstehe dass das jetzt für
leute die das noch nicht gemacht haben erst mal merkwürdig wirkt warum sollte
man sich steckdosen leiste mit kaufen mit web interface das web interface ist ja
nur das was ihr seht du kannst ohne probleme das web interface über die
passenden schrittstellen ansteuern aus der heim automatisierung raus also man
muss nicht den browser aufmachen um dann hier auf 12345 zu klicken und auch nicht
in um in die config zu gehen man stellt das in seiner heim automatisierung ein
und kann dann remote die sachen steuern übers tablet oder so oder sogar ganz
automatisch ein und ausschalten zum beispiel mal angenommen man hätte dort
einen was viele leute haben jemand wohnt unterm dach und hat irgendwie den
ventilator oder so oder eine klimaanlage und möchte schon wenn er auf dem heimweg
ist die klimaanlage einschalten er hat so eine kleine klimaanlage die ein von
strom anschließen muss dann kann er per heim automatisierung sagen ok ich sehe
mein herrchen ist auf dem heimweg im smartphone und dann schalte ich doch
schon mal die klimaanlage ein so und dann geht die heim automatisierung hin geht
über die api schrittstelle auf die steckdosen leiste und schaltet die
steckt schaltet den steckplatz ein wo die klimaanlage dran ist ist jetzt
nur ein beispiel für kann man alles mögliche mitmachen
beispielsweise habe ich drüben beim 3d trucker habe ich den kram auch nicht
habe den 3d trucker in einem also dafür ist unter anderem das wofür ich das jetzt
kommen will der 3d trucker kommt bei mir drüben ein und der raspberry pi kommt bei
mir drüben ein und die kamera kommt bei mir drüben ein sort sondern kann ich den
kram nämlich remote an und ausschalten es gibt jede menge so plugin steckdosen
also sprich halt wo nur ein anschluss ist da habe ich auch ein paar weil die man
siebe auf netzwerk erweitern aber oftmals hat man halt mehr als ein
gerät und es gibt doch wenig steckdosen die mehr als und vor allem noch mit usb
haben die man remote schalten kann und vor allem für 35 euro oder oder sogar
für 28 euro mit dem gutschein ist das im endeffekt eine ip steckdose für 30
euro da kann man sich nicht besperren so die sache hier würde ich nicht so viel
drauf geben weil dafür muss man die offizielle app verwenden und die
offizielle app verwende ich dafür nicht also wie gesagt nur kaufen wenn man
entweder die sache flaschen möchte oder wenn man okay damit ist dass man die
china cloud dafür braucht und ich wisst ja ich habe ich mag keine china cloud
deswegen kommt die wird die geflasht und kommt in ein eigenes china iot netz so
wie die hier auch und da kommt die nicht ins internet und nix und hat eine custom
firma drauf dass sie kann gar nicht mehr nach china sachen schicken und ich kann
sie trotzdem remote steuern also exzellent wunderbar so muss das sein
könnte man das teil auch aus einer net anwendung steuern klar natürlich du
kannst das motor kannst du über mqtt ansteuern über htp also über alles so
ziemlich über alles gebräuchliche kannst du das motor ansteuern
guck hier kannst mqtt konfigurieren du kannst auch direkt auf das auf die
adresse hier gehen man kann übrigens glaube auch ein
passport vergeben dass nicht jeder ein und ausschalten kann also man muss in
dem passenden wlan sein dass man das ein und ausschalten kann
also kann ich irgendwie jemand der mit dem zug gerade vorbeifährt meinen
steckdosenleister ausschalten oder so das wäre ein bisschen blöd
das ist übrigens ziemlich alte version die muss ich auch mal updaten
was gibt es dafür eine neue version sag ich mal her wir sind jetzt schon bei
8 guck mal die sind bei 8.10 und ich habe noch 65 da drauf schaubst du was
bestimmtes ja ich habe eine liste aber wir sind noch nicht allzu weit gekommen
erst zwei drei sachen
so und deswegen wie gesagt nur kaufen wenn man die wenn man das wenn man so
was selbst flaschen kann ich machte im nächsten stream wo wir das wieder mal
flaschen werden also wer dazu gucken will kann er jetzt schon mal folgen
exzellent und wahrscheinlich gucken wir uns dann am donnerstag und am
wochenende an ob man die neuen dinger flaschen kann
was habe ich da gerade gesehen in den akkuschrauber
gleich mal gucken also eine wasserwaage könnte ich
tatsächlich gebrauchen
so eine wasserwaage wäre nicht verkehrt ich glaube der hersteller ist auch ganz
gut ne
ich glaube die machen ganz ganz brauchbares zeug
da habe ich schon einen der habe ich auch schon exzellent ich könnte mir die
drei sachen kaufen die schon habe bis auf die wasserwaage
ja so eine so eine kleine wasserwaage könnte ich echt brauchen
ein hammer brauche ich nicht
kaufe empfehlung meinerseits in esp 82 66 ja hast du vollkommen recht
allerdings habe ich bestimmt noch an die 20 rumliegen
sandor 385 vier monate exzellent subscription also ich habe noch jede
menge esp 2866 rumliegen die 1 minis note mcs
was denn noch
hauptsächlich die 1 minis note mcs und was habe ich noch rumliegen
weiß schon gar nicht mehr ich muss ja ich muss dir ja nicht sagen ich habe auch
seit ich jetzt noch mit mit esp 32 angefangen habe
kaum noch was mit mit esp 82 66 gemacht ich finde es mit esp 32 einfach
deutlich angenehmer du hast zwei cpu kerne eigentlich sogar
drei cpu kerne so laut aber die low power kerne können wir erstmal weglassen
und ich finde es einfach deutlich angenehmer als im 2 in einem esp 82 66
aber meine abschlussprüfung den programmieren echt das für eine
abschlussprüfung gemacht also das interessiert mich jetzt weil also
wahrscheinlich nicht fahrinformatiker oder wahrscheinlich irgendwas in
richtung elektrotechnik oder so hey marx kannst du ein youtube video zu der
steckdosenleiste machen ich weiß nicht ob das die leute auf youtube so
interessiert aber muss ich nicht ich habe ja einen kompletten stream gemacht wo ich
die geflasht habe und wir mal gucken uns das am wochenende auch an ob man die
flaschen kann hier die die die ich hier gerade bestellt habe so
ach so ist ja sogar vier monate schon dabei kopf wird immer größer
so also wie gesagt kann das mit von allem von so ziemlich allem ansteuern was man
möchte so was was hatten jetzt noch für empfehlung hier baumarkt welche adapter
braucht man nicht fahrinformatiker anwendungsentwicklung esp echt als
anwendungsentwickler das das sieht man bei der iak aber bestimmt nicht oft
weil die iak ist ja schon gewöhnt dass quasi jeder zweite den ad aufbaut oder
irgendwie so komisches zeug
wlan ausleuchtung jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen dass sie das gut fanden
das ist ja auch mal ein bisschen was anderes nicht nicht das x wir bauen
einen vpn wir machen einen ad wir machen irgendwelche zabbix oder
irgendwelche nagi und früher haben sie nagios gemacht
ja das ist das ist nicht schlecht also ich glaube das gibt es da nicht so oft
warum hast du dich eigentlich für die ausführlich für ein studium entschieden
weil mein schulabschluss zu schlecht ist lowbrane und damals konnte man noch nicht
mit im realschulabschluss studieren heute geht das ja
ich war zu so das war das war der hauptgrund deswegen kam das auch
erst mal gar nicht in frage mittlerweile mittlerweile wäre das kein problem also
nur dass jetzt zu alt bin also ich habe ich habe keinen bock jetzt mit 35
doch mal was zu machen wo ne hättest du gerne studiert ehrlich gesagt
ne eigentlich nicht
ich gesagt nicht also ich finde das eigentlich ziemlich gut wie das gelaufen
ist was ich jetzt mache ich wüsste ich wüsste jetzt auch spontan nicht was mir
das da groß gebracht hätte zumindest das war jetzt mal wahrscheinlich würde ich
dann was ganz anderes machen ich gehe mal davon aus ich würde was ich würde
was ganz anderes machen wenn ich studiert hätte
ja wie gesagt wir gucken uns das mit dem flaschen auch an
oder es ist aber hier verena das ist ja massive brain hier zumal ein teil das
projekt zwar mit der drohne zum beispiel eine halle die signalstärke zu checken
und am ende habe ich es in einem was in einem chart grafisch dargestellt text
datei lässt sich text datei da kann man jetzt nicht allzu viel mitmachen also
aber so ein chart kommt bestimmt gut an das excellent exquisite abschlussprojekt
so machen wir mit der eigentlichen geschichte weiter wir sind doch nicht
alles zu weit gekommen also wie gesagt steckdoseleister habe ich bestellt das
probieren wir mal aus am wochenende oder irgendwann ende der woche mit der
steckdoseleister ob sich das flaschen lässt weil das letzte mal haben wir das
gemacht mit tuja convert das ist total easy gewesen damit
irgendeiner hat doch im chat gerade gefragt ich glaube der strelaug hat das
gefragt wie man das macht mit dem flaschen das letzte mal haben wir das
damit geflascht allerdings mittlerweile gibt es da eine neue version von weil die
alte nicht mehr geht also der flashvorgang funktioniert ungefähr so
du brauchst so ein raspberry pi und der raspberry pi macht einen wlan auf wo sich
die steckdose also der der benutzt quasi den gleichen wlan namen wie die chinesen
als sie die steckdoseleister hergestellt haben und da kann sich die
steckdoseleister irgendwie zu diesem wlan verbinden und dann machen sie
irgendwelche dinger und flaschen die steckdoseleister fragt mich nicht genau
aber du brauchst raspberry pi und damit kannst du die steckdoseleister flaschen
wenn es denn mit der aktuellen firme noch geht und ich habe nur gelesen dass es
mittlerweile probleme gibt und es jetzt irgendwie neue versionen davon gibt
keine ahnung das probieren wir dann aus wenn es soweit ist gut weiter geht's
weiter im text das haben wir schon ich überlege gerade wo sind wir stehen
geblieben genau steckdoseleister dann
das kriegen wir unten empfohlen das brauchen wir alles nicht so dann brauche
ich unbedingt wieder mikro sd karten allerdings nicht irgendwelche mikro sd
karten sondern die endurance mikro sd karten
weil der raspberry pi am 3d drucker ist schon wieder glaube ich zumindest dass
die sd karte kurz vorm abkacken ist und ich habe jetzt zwei kisten mit diesen
samsung endurance sd karten laufen seit einer weile und die machen überhaupt
keine probleme also bisher muss ich sagen ist das mit
abstand sind das mit abstand die besten sd karten die ich hatte wobei ich mir
nicht ganz das sind doch die falschen oder muss mal kurz in meiner meiner
bestell history nachgucken ich glaube das sind die falschen
endurance pro pro endurance muss man suchen genau das sind die da sind ja
eigentlich gut ja genau die braucht man exzellent pro endurance an die 64 sind
die gleichen plus im klein also die kann ich echt empfehlen aus aus dauernde sd
karten die sind bisher noch nirgendwo abgeraucht
die sind bisher wohingegen die billigen samsung sd karten davon davon da sind
die wo mir war mal 32 g das ist da wo mir amazon aus versehen mal einen 20er pack
oder so geschickt hat von denen ich habe ich habe mal bei amazon bestellt eine 32
g samsung micro sd karte 128 g von einem anderen hersteller 64 g und was habe ich
bekommen 128 g karte 64 g karte und irgendwie ein 20er pack 32 g da hat sich
entweder der typ im lager gedacht jolo juckt mich nicht ich weiß dem einfach
jetzt eine komplette packung rein oder irgendwas ist in der auftrags bearbeitung
schiefgegangen
zumindest micro sd karten mit 32 g habe ich echt genug mittlerweile aber von
diesen endurance sd karten habe ich nicht so viele und die kann ich die kann
ich echt empfehlen davon brauche ich mal kommen was nur drei stück
mehr nett tf also jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft
ich schließe doch keine versicherung ab für eine micro sd karte also man kann
es ja auch echt übertreiben ach hier geht jetzt mehr oder was ach nee
ja dann hat mein fing nur drei ok war mal chat habe ich gerade paar questions
übersehen gibt es eigentlich tools um usb sticks oder sd karten zu prüfen ja
aber ich kann ich kann ja aus dem kopf kann ich sagen wie der kam heißt das
sind das ist das ist dieses eine tool wo man auch damit die china usb sticks
immer enttarnen kann also die china usb sticks die sagen wir haben einen
terabyte und haben nur acht gigabyte ich weiß aber gerade aus dem kopf nicht
wie es heißt flintstone fragt für eine influx db mit sekundlichen schreib ok
also du meinst in flackstiby wo ordentlich was draufkommt mein sekundliche
schreiben wenn es nur ein wert ist dann ist das jetzt ja nicht sonderlich viel
usb stick oder ssd oder so eine endurance sd karte das beste was du machen kannst
ist eine ssd also wenn du wirklich ordentlich schreib lese performance
haben willst dann natürlich in der ssd aber der ssd ist halt gut ich erzähle
jetzt ja nichts neues aber big brainer ssd ist halt größer und liegt mehr im
weg aber wenn wenn du einfach nur sekundlich schreibst und paar werte
anders kauft ihr so eine endurance karte auf usb sticks kannst du echt keinen
kannst du keinen kannst du den nicht verlassen
usb sticks sind schrott zum größten teil die einzigen richtig guten usb sticks
sind die usb sticks die quasi nur usb zu m2 sind wo man eine eigene ssd
reinmacht die meisten anderen usb sticks sind einfach purer schrott und du
weißt nie wann er kaputt geht
schon mal usb boot getestet ja sogar im stream
aber und
ich kann sogar sagen wo nicht max fps moment ich bin ja der wupp los hier
guck mal da da sind wir doch schon endlich echt der usb boot betafilm
wo ja ja wenn du das wenn du den watt dazu sehen willst musst du ins archiv
gehen wir haben ja alle sachen im archiv du siehst dir der clip ist von 22
mai ich kann jetzt bei der gelegenheit mal zeigen wie das archiv funktioniert
geht mal ins archiv da gibt es hier so eine search txt sucht mir jetzt nach
boot
so und dann sieht man hier fünfter dings im ordner 05 22 links drinnen das
watt raspberry pi 4 endlich echter usb boot da
kann es dann hier reingehen und 5 und da oh nein nein nein ah gehst du fort ich
will das meine videos erholen und da hast du die sachen dann drinnen oder kannst
ihr das passende wort raussuchen zu
so funktioniert das archiv ich weiß nicht was aus dem neuen archiv geworden
ist dass man das durch suchbar machen kann ja also also flintstone einfache
sd karte killst du relativ schnell ich habe auch schon einige micro sd karten
gekillt damit deswegen bin ich irgendwann auf diese endurance micro sd karten
gekommen und da kann ich echt sagen die sind gut die taugen
aller raktur hast das ja ich glaube irgendwann setzen wir uns echt mal im
stream hin und basteln so archiv was durch suchbar ist
official da schreibt ich habe mal einige kilten mit idee mit idee kann es ja
ordentlich drauf schreiben wenn ihr das einen halben tag laufen lässt es halt
futsch so also endurance sd karten habe ich in wahren korb geschmissen alles klar
passt immer erst mal nur drei reicht aber wie gesagt 32 reichen und die sind
wirklich gut ich habe 264 und die sind relativ schnell für micro sd karten und
die halten wirklich ich vermute mal dass das unter der haube vielleicht mir
ein bisschen was von den ssd war was die auch in ihre ssd reinstecken drin ist
oder so keine ahnung dass ihr baro lebt ins archiv ja so sieht es aus
so also nächstes usb sticks haben wir micro sp ach so noch mal zum thema usb
sticks da kannst du dich echt nicht drauf verlassen
also usb sticks haben den hang dazu in den ungünstigsten momenten einfach
abzurauchen und gerade wenn man so was hier zum
beispiel kauft usb sticks 20er pack solche dinger ich habe mir bei aliexpress
auch mal ein paar usb sticks bestellt und die habe ich letztens mit auf die
arbeit gebracht und da hat sich halt mal rausgestellt also von 15 usb sticks oder
so war einer gleich kaputt und die sind halt langsam erst fack also das ist
absoluter müll also es ist jede micro sd karte besser als solche billig usb
sticks
generell usb sticks auch die auch die bisschen teureren die einzigen also die
einzigen usb sticks den ich traue sind usb zu m2 und dort eine ssd rein eine
richtige ssd
aber ich würde also ganz ehrlich gesagt ich würde ich würde zwar mit so einer
samsung endurance micro sd probieren die meisten usb sticks ja die meisten
usb sticks sind wirklich müll so also das muss ich mal kurz abhaken
micro sd karten hat man abgehackt ach ja jetzt muss jetzt müssen wir china
einkaufen und zwar dass ich gerade mit dieser kiste hier rum basteln
das haben wir haben wir im stream schon sogar im vorletzten stream haben wir
ein bisschen rum programmiert und ich habe gesehen also ich will mir davon
nicht noch mehr kaufen ich habe davon fünf das reicht ich habe gesehen die
haben was richtig cooles die haben was richtig cool also der gleiche hersteller
der diese boards macht ja kurz kurz wenn ich dabei war
wir haben letztens mit dem esp mit dem titi go hier sieht man es ja oben das
wichtig die wichtigste anwendung aller zeiten man braucht ja ja mit urzeit was
wir in dem stream gemacht haben ist übrigens so mini webserver zu programmiert
all das ist baro was jetzt los
wir haben so mini webserver programmiert der start ist html ausliefern kann so und
diese boards wo ihr hier oben eins seht
ähm ups
ach ja verena falls du noch da bist mit welches esp 32 port hast du genommen mit
batterie oder ohne batterie also batteriebetrieb oder kein batterie
betrieb weil ich hatte mit esp 2866 batteriebetrieb noch kein glück ich
habe ein paar esp 32 mit low low power boards verwendet die waren ganz
gut am esp 2866 habe ich da noch nichts gescheites gebacken bekommen so genau
und dieser hersteller der hat nämlich was richtig was richtig cool ist was ich
gesehen habe was ich unbedingt mal ausprobieren will der hat nämlich ein
t-call heißt das ding findest du einen dual micro sd adapter praktisch wüsste
ich nicht wozu man das braucht so weil also wüsste ich nicht wozu braucht man
dual micro sd adapter rate 1 drüber machen rate 0 micro sd
da weiß ich jetzt nicht rate 0 über micro sd kann ist das excellent oder ist
das eher low brain was was sagt ihr ist das ist das eher so oder ist das so
excellent low brain
es ist excellent ok ich weiß ja nicht
sie war was los mit der telekom 0,01 brain
ist eine gute micro sd in einem usb adapter besser als ein nativer usb stick
kommt das kommt auf den usb stick auf die micro sd karte an
es geht auch bei dir aber dir geht es nicht alles klar verstehe ja sagt ich
habe ich habe leider kein bild also ich habe ein voter von bild zum flame ich
habe einen bahn bild aber ich habe kein kein telekom bild
ja und was ich von denen mal ausprobieren wollte
was ich von denen mal ausprobieren wollte ist das ding hier und zwar ist das ein esp 32 mit
sim karte also mit sim sim slot keine ahnung ob das was taugt aber ich wollte
mir einfach mal ein bestellen zum ausprobieren und ganz ehrlich für neun
euro oder für neun dollar kannst du nicht als ich meine es ist es ist free
shipping wenn man noch ein bisschen was kauft und neun dollar da kannst du
wirklich nicht viel falsch machen und ich habe mir gedacht das ding hat gps und
sim slot hast du schon von dem neun telekom magenta 1 tarif gelesen ne magenta
eins den gehen auch die namen nicht aus oder
das ist android keine ahnung da habe ich wenig mitgemacht bisher so magenta
eins festnetz und mobilfunk vereint das ist was so ne habe ich ja nix gehört
sebaro das ist gut das gefällt mir das nehme ich mit auf was sagt ihr chat
das muss das muss ins bord rein oder das ist gut das gefällt mir
das ist das ist
telekom nicht teufel telekom
hallo und ah yes sehr schön exzellent telekom bild also das passt am besten
eigentlich zu magenta gaming weil das ist das ist richtig pence champ
zeig mal bitte das windows meinst das hier ok also was was soll das was soll
das tolles sein jetzt mobilfunk und festnetz inklusive
internet kombinieren was geht explizit um die verträge die haben immer so viel
glückliche leute auf ihren bildern wisst ihr was mich nervt hat es mit der
telekom nichts zu tun das wenn ihr die erwerbung anguckt ist mir heute ich ich
bin heute ein bisschen rumgelaufen da habe ich ein plakat gesehen von von
irgendeiner bank oder so keine ahnung ist auch vollkommen egal
da stand irgendwie so was drauf die beste vorsorge nur für sie ich was mir
was mir bei werbung immer so extrem auf den sack geht dass die dass sie nicht
einfach sagen können was sache ist dass sie oder generell dass die alle immer
so viel rum labern anstatt einfach zu sagen was sache ist ich mein geht denn
wirklich noch irgendein laden davon aus man kauft ihm ab dass er furchtbar an
mir interessiert ist und nur zu meinem besten handelt es ist doch vollkommen
bescheuert also keiner der das sagt macht das die sagen alle nur die beste
vorsorge für sie oder wir setzen uns für sie ein und so was in in in die
richtung totaler schwachsinn können die nicht einfach sagen was ist weil ich
mein mir ist es vollkommen klar dass ich den oder ihr oder wer auch immer geht
denen voll am arsch vorbei das geht ihnen voll am arsch vorbei es wird
deswegen wäre es doch besser wenn die einfach sagen würden ok wir bieten ihnen
das und das dann kann ich nämlich sagen ok ich weiß dass ich euch am arsch
vorbeigehe aber diese kondition also dieses angebot zu diesem preis finde ich
ok ja ihr müsst mich nicht mögen ich muss euch nichts nicht mögen es muss
ich einfach nur beide dran halten ich gebe euch kohle und ihr macht das dafür
oder umgedreht ihr gebt mir kohle ich mache was dafür
ja es gibt bestimmt genug leute die das glauben so ich bin nur grad wieder
basiert superglücklichen familienbild eingefallen die sollen einfach nicht so
sehr gefühle verkaufen die sollen einfach verkaufen und das dann halten
wisst ihr mir ist es viel lieber die würden hier oben gleich hinschreiben
aber da gehör ich wahrscheinlich zur zur minderheit es ist natürlich für
verkäufer ist es natürlich doof wenn man das so macht was ich sage weil ein
guter verkäufer kann er natürlich auch scheiße verkaufen und es macht er
bestimmt nicht indem ihr die fakten sagt weil dann verkauft er kaufst du es ja
nicht deswegen wäre es viel lieber anstatt dass die die glück dass die hier
permanent glückliche leute zeigen dass die einfach oben sagen würden keine
ahnung monatliche flatrate 400 g daun 100 g ab das und das garantiert
blablabla so wunderbar da müsste ich mir diesen ganzen schmodder jetzt gar nicht
angucken sondern wüsste gleich was sache ist und außerdem wer hat denn diese
seite designt da wieder kriegste wieder kriegste ja wie heißt das wenn man auf
dem schiff ist und kotzen muss da wirst du sehr krank genau also bei der seite
wirst du sehr krank wenn du dir das anguckst
scrollt damit habe ich verschluckt da wirst du wirklich sehr krank guckt euch
das mal an
motion sickness genau leute ich muss mal kurz das mikrofon abstöpseln irgendwie
bin ich gerade mit dem kabel drüber gefahren
so jetzt jetzt höre ich mich wieder auf der anderen seite hast du dir eigentlich
eine ps5 oder xbox vorbestellt nein hat am anfang einer gefragt schon stimmt
habe ich glaube ich gar nicht beantwortet mache ich auch nicht die xbox one und die
ps4 das war der größte konsolen fehlkauf aller
zeiten ich habe mir beide direkt zur release gekauft zwei ps5 auch noch gut
jeder wie er will ja ich sage nix das war der größte fehlkauf überhaupt weil ich
habe beide konsolen vielleicht ok ich habe die ps4 vielleicht länger also die
ps4 hatte ich vielleicht jetzt seit release sagen wir mal 20 stunden an und
die xbox hatte ich fünf stunden an ich meine what the fuck das hat sich
absolut nicht gelohnt total beknackt deswegen kaufe ich mir keine neuen
konsolen und die benahmung von microsoft macht mich total fertig ich habe keine
ahnung wie die neue konsole überhaupt heißt
ne kaufe ich nicht ich kaufe es mir vielleicht sobald es exklusiv titel gibt
die ich unbedingt spielen will genauso wie bei der switch die switch hat sich
im prinzip auch nicht gelohnt ich verwende die switch ja nicht mobil ich
verwende die switch ja auch nur stationär hier oben ich habe ganze drei
games für die switch ok also was was genau zu den angeboten was was sollten
wir denn jetzt hier gucken magenta eins plus tarif verzeihung ok 100 mbit pro
sekund zu hause mobil bis zu 100 mbit dauert es ist das nur dass ich das jetzt
kapiere ist das ein mobilfunk tarif mit home zone oder so was oder ist das dsl
und mobilfunk hybrid und beides zusammen oder eigentlich sind zwei getrennte
produkte nur zusammen verkauft werden das ist ein kombi vertrag das ist ein
kombi vertrag für festnetz und mobil ok also ist das ist das im prinzip
einen mobilfunk vertrag und ein festnetz vertrag in einem das bedeutet dass die
nicht etwa also dass man nicht die so ein hybrid router bekommt dass der der
das gab es ja mal es gab hier war so die magenta hybrid sondern man hat einfach
ein smartphone und man hat den dsl schluss ok verstehe also zeigt mal hier
ist das jetzt teuer oder nicht immer das weiß in deutschland bei mobilfunk
tarifen ja in deutschland ist ja alles teuer was das anbelangt tarif
monatlicher grundpreis 90 euro naja auf der anderen seite ich bezahle jetzt auch
irgendwie 75 euro für botafone allerdings sind es 75 euro für 400 mbit
down 100 mbit ab
fernsehe und halbdings kabelanschluss den man braucht ist quasi das was ich
jetzt bezahlt plus plus ja wahrscheinlich geht das sogar so also
zeig mal tarif details monatlicher grundpreis 70 euro einmal bestellen 70
euro mindestens läuft es auch kein das ist schon mal gut weil wo davon macht
er immer noch diesen zwölf monate kacke
also ich muss sagen wo davon hat es jetzt hingekriegt nachdem sich ja
in den community type manager vermute ich meinem problem angenommen hat hat
hatte weil ich täglich auf twitter geflämt habe habe ich keine probleme
mehr also ich habe so lange auf twitter geflämt bis ich irgendwann mal ich
vermute halt bei der art und weise wieder geschrieben hat dass das irgendein
in den community manager oder sowas war dass ich darum gekümmert hat und
wahrscheinlich haben die mich jetzt auf irgendwas irgendwas anderes intern
umgelegt umgestuft wo nur die nerven in leute drauf kommen die zu die zu sehr
rum nerven oder die zu viele auf twitter haben die das lesen keine ahnung
zumindest ist seitdem die das gefixt haben seitdem der typ sich da
eingeschaltet hat alles alles top bei botafone
also telefonieflatt sms dass die das heute überhaupt noch drauf schreiben
sms flatt ist das wirklich noch ein verkaufskriterium sms flatt ja
wahrscheinlich schaue ich bei der boomer bei der boomer generation ist das so
oh geil sms flatt das kaufe ich das sind die gleichen leute ich kann mich
dann noch richtig dran erinnern das sind die gleichen leute die sich dann immer
die so die gedacht haben sie sind jetzt die übelst krassen heckermans die sich
damals whatsapp installiert haben und sich dann gegenseitig immer erzählt
haben kennst du schon kennst du schon diese neue app mit der man kostenlos
sms verschicken kann was kostenlos sms verschicken
unglaublich da muss ich mich gleich registrieren so typischer typischer
boomer talk was whatsapp angeht
da muss ich mal was sagen ich bin ja der ober boomer was whatsapp angeht ich habe
noch nicht mal whatsapp
und ich wehre mich auch dagegen whatsapp zu installieren
ich habe bisher alles alles erfolgreich evaded was mich zu whatsapp überreden
wollte sogar das weihnachtsgrill von vor zwei jahren schon wieder zweier her
sogar dort habe ich whatsapp evaded sagen die whatsapp mache ich nicht
will ich nicht ich kann es dir gar nicht so hundertprozentig begründen weil ich
nicht mehr mein zeug verteilen will als nötig was mir bei diesen ganzen
benutzte telegramm signal benutze ich notgedrungen was mir bei den ganzen
messenger apps voll auf den sack geht ist dass die deine kontakte
benachrichtigen dass du jetzt diese messenger app hast ich habe signal
installiert und habe extra gesagt nein ich möchte meine kontakte nicht
scheren und zwei tage später sagt einer zu mir
ach max du hast jetzt auch signal weißt du woher weißt du dass ich hab meine
kontakte nicht geschert ja signal hat mir bescheid gesagt
wtf also die sagen jemanden bescheid wenn der mich im kontaktbuch hatten ich mich
angemeldet habe und dann werbeste alles samt damit so nach dem motto auf voll
privacy und anonym und mit uns und da geht das überhaupt nicht und privacy und
anonym und dann sowas total bescheuert also ganz ehrlich wenn ich wenn ich mit
jemandem kontakt treten möchte über signal dann mache ich das da müssen die
denn nicht bescheid sagen wird gekauft der vertrag oder ich bin gerade noch mal
am gucken weil mich jemand gefragt hat was ich davon halte ganz ehrlich kein
schimmer ich kenne mich mit mobilfunk verdrängen nicht aus
es hat besteht nur in der hälfte aus fußnoten wie viel bandbreite wie viel
unbegrenztes datenvolumen in deutsch 5g ok was ist die fußnote zu 5g ok die
fußnote zu 5g ist verbreitet corona oder so ne wahrscheinlich einfach nur
dass es nicht überall verfügbar ist 5g ist deutschland bereits an vielen
standorten verfügt naja naja wir wollen wir wollen wir wollen jetzt mal nicht
übertreiben wir wollen jetzt mal nicht übertreiben
ich würde sagen 5g ist deutschland auch an manchen standorten schon verfügbar
nein das will ich mir nicht holen hat mich nur jemand gefragt
das ist doch in ordnung hat die telekom hat die telekom ein hat die telekom so
was auch ohne festnetz gibt es bei der telekom sowas ohne festnetz
ja für 90 ja aber das kostet auch 90 euro ok jetzt muss ich jetzt mal gucken
ob die auch so was haben zu den angeboten zu den jang tarifen also quasi
der pedo bär tarif oder was darf man sich da drunter vorstellen zu den
smartphone tarifen ok unbegräbt was
und nämlich veräppeln
also also ich habe jetzt nur dass ich es jetzt verstehe ich habe die auswahl
zwischen 90 euro flatrate festnetz und mobilfunk ein monate kündigung oder 82
81 nur mobilfunk flatrate mit 24 monaten vertragslaufzeit hä also im
prinzip ist dann es besser wenn ich das ding hier kaufe und dann habe ich noch
einen backup anschluss daheim falls mal wo davon wiederum spackt mit der
bereitstellungspreis der juckt mich jetzt nicht
also das heißt ich könnte jetzt noch mal 90 euro im monat ausgeben ich hätte
einen backup anschluss unbegrenztes und unbegrenztes mobiles internet
exzellent also ich finde ich finde gar nicht übel ich finde ganz ehrlich ich
finde ich finde 90 euro für deutschland ja muss man jetzt mal sagen ich finde
das ein absolutes unding dass eine mobilfunk flatrate 90 euro im monat
kostet das ist ein absolutes unding in anbetracht der tatsachen wie teuer das
scheiß in deutschland ist ist das aber gar nicht mal so schlecht was dass sie
nur 54 geben nee in der eu in deutschland ist es unlimited stand hier
drinne unbegrenztes datenvolumen in deutschland innerhalb der eu 54 g also
ich finde ich finde es komplett für den arsch dass es das eine flatrate
mobilfunk so teuer ist in deutschland dann muss man nach anderen länder ich
weiß nicht er hat nicht letztens einer in der schweiz erzählt dass es das der
patrick könnte gewesen sein dass er irgendwie gefühlt die hälfte kostet in
der schweiz in die sachen sonst teurer es gibt auch noch mehr länder wir
müssten irgendwann mal vergleich gucken also 90 euro ist halt viel viel viel zu
viel wenn man sich überlegt ich musste letztens auf der arbeit ein paar isos
runterladen über über lte und da kannst du super günstig bei der telekom also
super günstig in anführungsstrichen kannst du bei der telekom für fünf
euro eine daily flat buchen fünf euro fünf euro wtf daily flat datennutzung
fünf euro ich glaube 55 oder so sind die sind die
irgendwie noch ganz bei troste tja gut eigentlich wollte ich einkaufen
was recht in norwegen ist kein wunder dass die glücklicher sind in norwegen
arbeiten ja bloß vier tage die woche also sie machen quasi das was ich auch
mache aber jeder
aber das war das morg norwegen die finden wollen auch
also die norweger sind gut ja ich mag die norweger also wenn ich mir ein land
aussuchen müsste außer deutschland dann wäre es wahrscheinlich norwegen oder
finnland oder dänemark dänemark ist auch nice dänemark norwegen oder finnland nur
mit dem unterschied ich kann halt absolut null die sprache also und und und für
jemand der der deutsch halbwegs englisch kann ist halt norwegisch und
finnisch ist halt echt so so elfen sprache quasi das ist wie als bist du
irgendwie herr der ringe oder so gelandet so elfisch hört sich das an
den ich versteht man die ein oder anderen wörter ja
aber viel also also dänisch verstehst du so ein paar wörter weil die sich
ähnlich anhören aber finnisch ist echt nicht von dieser welt so
also wir machen ich muss jetzt einmal weiter einkaufen also paar sachen haben
wir ja schon ein paar sinnvolle dinger gefunden und die wollte ich auch haben so
das was darf mir das nicht empfehlen
dabei sind amazon das ist das ist schlimm man muss sagen also diese amazon
algorithmus der empfiehlt mir oft dinger die ich wirklich kaufen will dann was
pb-swiss warum nicht wäre wäre es somit mein lieblingshersteller letztendlich
kannst du mit den ganzen mit den meisten hi hi dings der hersteller nicht viel
sei es wie her wäre stahlwelle was auch immer nur das kannst ja alles geben und
das ist auch alles gut
man kann es natürlich übertreiben man kann auch für eine zange 3000 euro
ausgeben aber muss man nicht das ist ein bisschen so wie bei kopfhörern man kann
sich ohne probleme richtig richtig gute kopfhörer kaufen für 2300 euro so man
kann auch 4000 euro ausgeben 55 optionen black laser was ist denn hier der
unterschied da mehr dabei was torx eget ist sofort torx torx habe ich schon das
hat mir das weihnachtsgrill geschenkt vor zwei jahren ein vera torx set
ja also das ist also die wäre dinger sind wirklich also ich habe ja relativ
viel wäre wäre werkzeug da hat ich ist mir ist noch nichts kaputt gegangen
bisher
ich glaube mir ist irgendwie so dann also der ist denn hier der unterschied
dazwischen außer dass die unterschiedlich farbe haben hex plus
edelstahl hex black laser hf ist das halt die fresse black laser torx die torx
freundin was ist denn da der unterschied einfach nur so das finish oder wie
halt die fresse und gibt mir den geld weiß ich okay leute ich muss ich habe
quasi den richtigen check gewürfelt ich ich wieder stehe der sache jetzt und
kauft das nicht kann ich kann ich immer alles ins den kaufen weiß ich was ich
gerne hätte ich mein eigentlich schon wenn man mal ehrlich ist also eigentlich
könnte eigentlich könnte ich da schon machen aber es ist es wieder strebt mir
auf der anderen seite auch das zu machen ich gebe ja sonst nicht ich gebe ja
sonst kein geld aus gott alpha getestet nö ps4 kriege ich ich habe zwei linke ps4
hände
aber brauche ich nicht habe ich schon außer die kombi zange so eine
knippex kombi zange wäre tatsächlich nicht verkehrt jetzt nicht weiter gucken
nicht weiter gucken sonst kaufe ich den kram noch
mach einfach ein paar youtube videos easy money easy life
ne easy money easy life es geht noch viel besser einfach instant jetzt alle auf
twitch subscriben muss nie wieder youtube videos machen so ach ja ich brauche
unbedingt neue mäuse denkt sich amazon amazon da legste falsch neue mäuse
brauche ich nicht leuchtpapier twitch excellent subscription da hier die
substans gehen hoch so jetzt muss ich was ernsthaft mal was was gucken also das
ding wollte ich mir bestellen genau ad card sonst vergesse ich das das ist da
war ich nämlich gerade dabei das ist ein esp 32 modul mit gps und eine
eingebauten eingebauten sim slot und ich habe mir überlegt wenn das halbwegs
stromsparend ist dann werde ich lieber das verwenden anstatt zu meinen meine
laura geschichte für den friedhof
weil es kostet auch nicht so viel es gibt datentarife für glaube 150 im
monat wieso bei dir 99 und bei mir 13 euro tja
excellent wahrscheinlich hast du das falsche land ausgewählt wahrscheinlich
hast du das falsche land ausgewählt guck hier uk ist 13 euro china ist noch
hoffnung in bettel viel nächstes jahr bisschen nicht viel
mann grabat ja ja gut ich meine ich wie wisst ihr ich kaufe unter drei kaufe
ich nix also noch zwei stück dabei da kennt ihr ja meine devise unter drei
wird nix gekauft lohnt sich nett wenn man aus china bestellt ist ist fakt also
für ein teil aus china bestellen ist bescheuert
so und das probieren wir dann mal aus weil dann werde ich die laura geschichte
vielleicht durch den durch den durch den bord ersetzen mit mobilfunk
so das wollte ich haben so muss ich gleich mal abhaken kurz
also mikro sd kanama titi go t-call hatten wir was kostet eigentlich eine
windows lizenz ist jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was kostet eine windows 10
lizenz auf aliexpress was schätzt ihr leute ich habe noch nie nachgeguckt was
meint ihr 250
drei euro sieben vielleicht kriegen wir sogar eine windows lizenz plus office
easy also 450 450 für windows 10 und office 2019 professional plus was will
der amazon für ist das legit so lange sich aktivieren lässt okay also ich
meine man kriegt auch in deutschland relativ seriös günstig windows 10 kies
da kriegt auch für 10 15 euro oder sowas aber nicht ganz so billig
license expert kommt euch dieser usb stick bekannt vor leute kommt euch
dieser usb stick bekannt vor
sogar die ecke ist gleich guck mal das ist original das ist original der billig
aliexpress usb stick die gibt es massig die gibt es an jeder ecke an jeder
ecke jetzt hier beim schiener mann sind die nur viel günstiger klar das ist viel
zu teuer also damit euch los 47 euro ich glaube es geht los bei aliexpress kostet
ich probiere das mal aus ich probiere das mal aus ich will wissen ob da kram
funktioniert no para bowie das ist richtig ich weiß nicht ob das noch
gilt aber so habe ich das damals auch gemacht
er schreibt wo ist er hier er schreibt auf mmuga kostet windows 7 pro 449 dann
kann man ja kostenlos auf windows 10 abgründen genauso habe ich das auch
gemacht ich habe nur windows 7 lizenz damals gekauft
windows 8 lizenz und ich glaube noch noch ein paar windows 7 lizenzen weil man
die alle abgründen konnte für den apple und nahe auf windows 10 und ich weiß
aber nicht ob es noch geht also ihr meint das geht nicht oder was wenn ich
chat verstehe ich euch richtig das geht nicht mit dem office
doch ok was kostet es auf ebay windows 10 da wird es aber jetzt schon leute
das ist das dreifache wie auf aliexpress
also ich bin ja geneigt ich bin ja geneigt es mal auszuprobieren ob das
funktioniert
alle wie beschrieben arbeitete alle danke alles wie beschrieben alles
arbeitete danke was ach so das ist die aliexpress translation
deswegen hört sich das so merkwürdig an
ja ich habe noch nicht gecheckt wie man bei aliexpress sich die sachen einfach
im original anzeigen lassen kann vielleicht soll ich mal zumindest auf
englisch stellen für comrades sind am start
ok dann lohnt sich dann lohnt sich nicht ok wenn es die sogar schon bei
seriöseren quellen in deutschland gibt für den gleichen preis dann lohnt sich
jetzt echt nicht bei aliexpress
zeigst du es im stream lieber nicht im stream zeigen ist glaube ich nicht so
gut
ich brauche aktuell auch überhaupt keine windows mich hat es einfach nur
interessiert mich hat es einfach nur mal interessiert was bei aliexpress
windows keys kosten das alles will gar nix gar keine windows keys kaufen also
vertraust du deinem cute chat nicht um ehrlich zu sein
ne außer dem michael 50 billionen dem natürlich schon aber dem restlichen
nein auf gar keinen fall vielleicht vielleicht im cute mod noch man muss
sagen man muss ja schon sagen der chat ist manchmal doch echt big brain also
gerade wenn ich irgendwelche sachen am basteln bin und der chat mir schon sagt
was verkehrt ist bevor ich selber merke dass ich mich vertippt habe das ist dann
teilweise schon wirklich ja big brain und das kommt oft vor also man sieht
schon im chat haben wir auch viele leute die durchaus ahnung haben von dem von
dem zeug das ist quasi so art per programming genau
guck mal die empfehlen mir kameras mal gucken ob da was gutes bei es
oh eine auto kamera für 1734 die wird bestimmt richtig gut sein
kein photoshop alles echt
ätio das ist natürlich herr
alles klar ins作 sem
INAUDIBLE
Kruxsett
Zumindest mal ein Stecker, zumindest mal ein Stromstecker, der mir passen würde. Wie sieht es in Russland aus?
Haben die da 110-230 Volt? Gleich ein Stecker wie bei uns?
Aha, aha.
Wollt ihr was machen?
Wahrscheinlich ist jetzt eine Delle drin in der 17-Euro-Kamera.
Okay, ich glaube, das ist doch keine Outdoor-Kamera.
Ich meine 17 Euro.
Ich meine 17 Euro. Moment, es ist eine 17-Euro-Kamera mit Tilt?
Okay, das kann eigentlich nur Schrott sein. Das kann eigentlich nur totaler Schrott sein.
Das kann eigentlich nur Schrott sein.
Wie willst du das Kabel draußen dran machen durch Fenster legen? Ja, ja. Die sind ja recht dünn.
Oder du hast, also das Kabel musst du ja nicht durchmachen. Du machst ja, ähm, hier deine Netzwerkkabel rein und das musst du dann halt in dünn machen.
Es gibt ja so extra flache Netzwerkkabel.
Okay, die Software sieht aus wie von 1995. Winamp. Opera. Wie alt ist das Video schon?
Okay, ein FPS. Angeblich ist das von heute.
Aber viel FPS hat es nicht. Die wollen mir wirklich erzählen, dass es eine Outdoor-Kamera ist mit Motor, die man steuern kann, für 17 Euro.
Und die man dann auch noch über den Browser angucken kann und wahrscheinlich schon RTSP hat.
Die Russen haben gerne so Dashcams, die nehmen gerne Straßen auf, wie die Leute crashen und so. Es gibt so viele, diese ganzen Dashcam-Videos, die kommen alle aus Russland.
Okay, ist gut jetzt. Ach, minus 74 Prozent. Okay, das, ich glaube, das will ich nicht. Also man kann aus China bestellen.
EU-Stecker. Man kann aus China bestellen oder aus Russland. Russland liefert nicht nach Germany. Okay, also ich muss aus China bestellen. Alles klar.
Und es kostet mir nicht mal versammt. Derox, 10 Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub. 10 Monate, das ist 2 Monate vor. Also ist es nur, nur. Aber Big Brain Subscription.
Ab 12 Monate ist eindeutig. Dankeschön für 10 Monate. Poggers. Das ist bestimmt, das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht. Das ist bestimmt so ein Wettbewerb.
Wer kann mehr Spyware in die Firmware packen? Die Russen oder die Chinesen? Gucken, wer gewinnt. Alter, warum ist der Knopf verkehrt?
Also ich habe ja heute schon ein paar Mal aus Versehen geklickt. Obwohl ich eigentlich klicken wollte. Weil auch nicht.
Ach stimmt, Android 11 ist raus. Könnten wir uns vielleicht noch angucken nachher. Allerdings die Android Fragmentierung ist ja auch real.
Okay, kein Photoshop. Alles klar. Okay, machen wir hier auf Englisch. Ich muss das in irgendeiner Sprache lesen, die ich verstehe, die nicht dann auch noch auf Deutsch übersetzt wird.
Oder ist es in Russisch geschrieben? Midnight Vision. Hat die RTSP? Die haben bestimmt RTSP.
Kein Stockfoto, by the way. Kein Stockfoto. Legit. Und die Kamera hängt da auch wirklich. Die Kamera ist da nicht einfach nur rein Photoshopped.
Und die hängt auch da. Die größten Verhältnisse sind ja auch wie in echt. Guck mal. Die Kamera ist größer als das Garagentor.
Die Kamera ist größer als der Einbrecher, Alter.
Excellent. Okay, ich bin echt geneigt, mir für 17 Euro das Ding zu bestellen. Zu gucken, ob man da RTSP-Stream von machen kann.
Guck mal, es gibt sogar Testbild. Das sieht aus wie eine Alien-Entführung. Das sieht doch nicht aus wie eine Kamera. Das sieht aus, als latsen die Aliens gerade irgendwo.
What the fuck? Was soll das sein? Was sehe ich da? Ah, das ist die Kamera. Jetzt erkenne ich es. Das ist eine WLAN-Antenne.
Das ist hier die Kamera. Und das sind drei LEDs von der Kamera. Ich habe aber echt eine Weile gebraucht, bis ich das erkannt habe, was das sein soll.
Okay, hier erkennt man es jetzt besser. Über RTSP hat man immer noch Delay. Also wirklich schneller als RTSP.
Das Delay kommt meistens nicht über RTSP. Das Delay kommt entweder beim Encoding, dass der zu wenige Keyframes macht und sonst was.
Also man kriegt über RTSP, wenn man die Kamera richtig einstellt, nahezu ohne Delay rüber.
Vielleicht 300-400 Millisekunden, wenn es hochkommt durch RTSP. Kommt halt drauf an, wie der Rest eingestellt ist.
Excellent Product. So Leute, ich bestelle mir das jetzt. Ich bestelle mir das Teil jetzt für 17 Euro und gucke, ob das funktioniert.
Was ist das für ein Hersteller? Joann? Joann? Welche Kamera ist das? Joann-Camera. RTSP. Die haben echt ein RTSP?
Model. Welches Model ist das? Model? Ja, alles klar.
Wahrscheinlich haben die echt nett. Okay, ich bestelle mir das Ding jetzt für 17 Euro und wahrscheinlich kriege ich dann irgendwie Hautausschlag, wenn ich es angreife oder so.
Ich bestelle mir das Ding. Für 17 Euro kannst du nichts falsch machen. Geld wäre besser in die Heckschlüssel investiert. Da hast du eigentlich auch recht.
Haben die ein Manual dabei? Okay, haben die eine Webseite dieser komischen Hersteller? Shenzen. Was sonst? Was sonst?
Okay, die Seite gibt es schon gar nicht mehr. Die Seite ist schon down.
Joann-Products. Also, 3 Megapixel IP-Kamera. Gucken wir mal, ob wir die da finden.
Hä?
Funktioniert ja richtig. Wenn die Webseite schon so gut funktioniert. Support. Ich will ein Manual. Ich will download. Die Webseite geht schon richtig gut.
Download. Ich brauche ein Manual zu der Kamera.
Was ist das für nervige Musik? Das hört sich an wie dieser komische Flötenmensch aus der Ubisoft Präsentation.
Okay. Wireless Shake Head Misch. Was? Eine Wireless Kopfschüttelmaschine? Was?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur geile Übersetzungen. Ich glaube, die meinen Wireless Kamera, die man drehen und kippen kann.
Drehen, also Pan, Tilt. Was heißt denn das? Drehen und kippen.
Okay, man findet hier nichts auf der Seite. Nichts. Und Products gibt es auch nichts. Also äußerst vertrauenswürdige Hersteller würde ich sagen.
Also meine erste Wahl für Kameras natürlich.
Scam. Das Problem ist, die meisten China Webseiten sind so und die Dinge gibt es wirklich und funktionieren. Contact Us. Klar.
Ach so, da muss ich hinfahren. Das ist klar.
We are here. Das bringt mir äußerst viel, dass ich weiß, wo ihr in Shenzhen sitzt.
Fast Link. Okay, von wann sind die letzten News? Von 2016. Okay, die gibt es nicht mehr. Die verkaufen irgendwelche ollen Kameras, die es nicht mehr gibt.
Die einfach nur übrig sind, wo es niemals wieder was geben wird für.
Meinung zu Unraid. Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert. Ich kenne es, ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert. Ich hatte bisher noch keinen Anwendungszweck für.
Ich bestelle mir so ein Teil. Ich probiere das aus. Aber ich muss mich da einloggen. Ich bestelle mir so ein Teil.
Ich will einfach wissen, ob der Scheiß funktioniert und ob der RTSP hat und ob man den wirklich steuern kann und ob man krank wird, wenn man es anfasst.
Guck mal, das ist die Kamera, die ich bei Amazon bestellt habe. Die habe ich bei Amazon bestellt, für nicht viel mehr.
Aber ich habe mir die Wifi-Variante bestellt. Bei Amazon kostet die 35.
Für so viel habe ich mir die nicht bestellt. Was kostet die in China?
In China kostet die ein bisschen weniger würde ich sagen.
Five Day Delivery. Meinung zu ESX Ion Arm ist mir neu, dass es es dafür gibt. Aber wenn, finde ich es eine coole Sache.
Das heißt, ich kann ein ESX auf einem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen oder wie?
Wie kommst du da drauf? Geht das?
Ja, so in dem Dreh habe ich glaube ich auch bezahlt. Das lohnt sich aber.
Das sieht man mal wieder. Amazon möchte dafür aktuell 74 Euro und AliExpress oder was will Banggood? Guck mal was Banggood will. Gar nichts. Was will Gearbest? Gar nichts. Aber AliExpress will dafür 30 Euro weniger.
Kann man sich echt nicht beschweren. Warum gibt es die denn gefühlt 100 Mal hier?
AliExpress sieht immer so aus wie ein asiatischer Klon. Den Zusammenhang kann ich jetzt nicht herstellen, weil AliExpress ist ja das Original China Shopping Experience.
Da gibt es zwei Stück. Da wollen sie mehr. Warum ist das aus Australien so günstig?
Warum kostet das aus Australien weniger? Ach so, liefert nicht nach Deutschland. Verstehe, verstehe.
Okay, war es doch immer genug Kamera jetzt geguckt weg. Also da kannst du ja wirklich auch. Okay Leute wisst ihr was? Ihr habt mich überzeugt.
Wenn ich mir die komische Kamera kaufen kann für 17 Euro einfach nur, damit ich mich drüber lustig machen kann, kann ich mir auch was richtiges kaufen für das gleiche Geld.
Ach so, dann verstehe ich, das stimmt. Dann kaufe ich mir jetzt noch den... Was ist denn der Unterschied dazwischen? Oh, da sind die fetten.
Was ist das für ein Schlüssel? Kannst du da mit dem Save aufbrechen oder? Was sind das für ultrafette Emos Schlüssel?
Die hier sind nicht ganz so fett. Also das ist bis 5. Das hier ist auch bis 5. Aber da hinten, das sind mega fett.
So sieht es aus Stripes, wenn sie mich kaufen, nicht offline ein. Ich glaube, dass ich im Heimbereich mit der Sache besser fahre als mit dem fetten Satz.
Weil ich habe keine Schrauben oder Sachen, wo das reinpasst. Und da gibt es doch das, das verwirrt mich.
Das kann ich mir jetzt nicht direkt bestellen, weil ich muss erstmal gucken, was ich mir davon am besten kaufe. Ich glaube, den da. So, exzellent.
Die sind nur kürzer, nicht dicker. Weißt du? Nee. Guck mal, das ist doch viel fetter. Oder ist das Perspektive, die mich gebadet?
Okay, also was ist drinne? Wo steht, was drinne ist? Bis 10. Tatsächlich. Tatsächlich.
Alter, das hier sieht dreimal dicker aus als das. Also guckt mal. Das ist aber mal richtig.
Ja, also das heißt, ich muss mich jetzt zwischen kurz und dick und lang und dick entscheiden quasi.
Dann nehme ich trotzdem lang und dick, weil man da mehr Kraft aufbringen kann.
Ich doch richtig, oder? Was ist der Vorteil? Warum sollte man sich kurz und dick kaufen anstatt lang und dick?
Ernst gemeinte Frage. Jetzt in Bezug auf die Schlüssel. Wenn die lang zu lang sind, da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen. Was für einen Anwendungszweck könnte das sein?
Ja, genau, dass man lange manchmal braucht als anstatt kurze kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber für was? Okay, doch, doch, doch. Ein Anwendungsgebiet fällt mir halt ein. Zum Beispiel, wenn man in einem Gehäuse einen Lüfter festdreht. Allerdings macht man das nicht damit.
Wenn man im Gehäuse irgendwie Lüfter festdrehen muss oder sowas, dann ist sowas hier vielleicht besser. Übrigens, by the way, wo ich gerade das Ding hier noch mal sehe. Toolcheck plus beste Investition.
Also wenn ihr zu wenig Werkzeug daheim habt und ihr was braucht, mit dem ihr viel machen könnt, holt euch ein Toolcheck plus. Das Ding ist wirklich, ich bin nicht gesponsort, aber das Ding ist wirklich extrem.
Das ist wirklich super. Damit könnt ihr gefühlt 50% der Arbeiten, die im Haushalt anfallen, erledigen. Ja, natürlich, wenn ihr eine Zange braucht oder nicht. Aber 50% der sind eh, irgendwas muss ab dran, wie auch immer gedreht, geschraubt werden und das könnt ihr damit machen. Exzellent, wahnsinnig exzellent.
So, next. Oh, wir haben schon fast, wir haben fast 22 Uhr. Wie geht das denn so schnell? Was haben wir denn zwei Stunden gemacht?
Ich meine das ernst, was haben wir zwei Stunden gemacht? Nix, ja genau, deswegen, die können doch keine zwei Stunden rum sein. Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Fake News. Fake News, das stimmt nicht. NTP Verschwörung.
Doch, doch, eingekauft habe ich die auf dem zweiten Rechner die Steckdosenleiste und den Kram hier kaufe ich auch jetzt ein. Allerdings, ich lock mich nicht im Stream ein. Ich merke mir das hier nur vor und kaufe es dann vom anderen Account aus.
Einfach andere Zeitzone einstellen. Ah, yes. Okay, dann gucken wir jetzt noch schnell was anderes nach. Nämlich auch auf Aliexpress oder Banggood oder GearBest, mal schauen.
Ich habe jetzt letztens gelesen, dass neben den ESP32 jetzt STM32 voll im Trend sind. Hat jemand von euch schon mal STM32 verwendet?
Da gibt es wohl angeblich aus China so schwarze, so schwarze, solche Boards hier. Black Pill, sowas hier. Und die sollen wohl relativ günstig und gut sein.
Was mich da allerdings ein bisschen dran abschreckt ist, ich habe keinen WLAN. Kennst du etwas ESP-like mit ZigBee? Leider nicht.
Es gibt einen offiziellen ZigBee Arduino, der ist aber viel zu teuer. ZigBee Uno oder irgendwie so heißt das Ding. Oder war das SeaWave Uno? Moment, nicht dass ich das jetzt durcheinander bringe.
Ach, nicht SeaWave Uno war das. Aber viel, viel zu teuer. Ich meine, sind die noch bei Trost? 57 Euro für ein DevBoard? Nee. Nee, ich kenne keinen ZigBee.
Leider nicht. Das ist alles so ein halbpropritärer Kram. Wobei SeaWave ja gar nicht, aber leider gibt es da nichts ordentliches offenes für.
Hat Dissortion, hast du so ein Ding schon mal ausprobiert? Die Sache ist halt, ich weiß nicht, was ich damit machen soll. Nicht, dass mich das abhalten würde, den Kram zu kaufen.
Aber ohne WLAN weiß ich halt echt nicht, was ich damit machen soll. Ein WLAN ist halt, du musst ja irgendwie dich connecten zu dem Kram. Ich könnte es noch nicht mehr für die Tür-Gegensprechanlage verwenden.
Sind die wenigsten Stromsparender als ein ESP32? Weil, dass die jetzt wirklich viel schneller sind als ein ESP32, glaube ich nicht. Die sind wahrscheinlich sogar eine ganze Ecke langsamer als ein ESP32.
Und ich rede nur von einem Core. Der ESP32 hat ja noch einen zweiten Core. Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich damit machen sollte, aber...
Man kann sich das schon mal vor... Wobei, nee, brauche ich... Ganz ehrlich, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich damit machen soll, das kaufe ich nicht.
Machs gut, Stripes107. Nee, nee, nee, das kaufe ich. Ich muss nicht jeden Mist kaufen.
Das hake ich mal ab. Ich muss nicht jeden Mist kaufen.
Dann brauche ich noch eine USB-Verlängerung. Irgendwas... Was ist denn das? Was ist denn die längste USB... Oh, 5 Meter, das wäre ja Poggers, wenn das funktioniert.
Am besten natürlich auch eine USB-3-Verlängerung. Ob die funktioniert? Ja, manchmal braucht man das leider, USB-Verlängerung. Ich finde es auch kacke.
Manchmal brauche ich nur USB-Verlängerung. Das ist nur aktiv. Also, das ist eine USB-2. Okay, dann gibt es das nicht mit 5 Metern.
2 Meter. Amazon Basics. Also, manchmal kommt man halt nicht drum herum. Manchmal hast du zum Beispiel meine Kamera. Die hat halt einen USB-Stecker dran.
Das ist richtig dumm. Den kannst du neben so reinstecken und dann ist der kaum zu sehen. Aber die hat halt einen USB-Stecker fest dran und dann brauchst du halt eine Verlängerung.
Was, du hast eine 10 Meter USB-Verlängerung, aber die macht kein USB-3, oder? Das ist nur USB-2. Wobei, ganz ehrlich, USB-2-Verlängerung reicht auch dicke. Doch, 3? Echt, sag mal, wie heißt denn die?
10 Meter. TF. Ah, hier. Ja, sowas ist doch nice. 10 Meter USB-Aktivverlängerung. Ugreen. Ja, das ist nicht übel. Sowas holen wir mal.
Nein, warum wollen die mir immer für diesen ganzen Müll eine Versicherung andrehen? Wer kauft sich für einen USB-Kabel eine Versicherung? Oder echt 2 Jahre extra Garantie?
Wer macht das? Warum? Das gibt für mich absolut keinen Sinn. Okay, also das haben wir. Muss ich abhaken? Muss ich abhaken? USB-Verlängerung?
So, letzte Sache, die ich mir schon längere Zeit holen will, weil das super praktisch ist, stelle ich mir zumindest so vor, super praktisch ist für Pakete öffnen und generell Sachen auspacken. Also für alle, die Dr. Max nicht sehen wollen,
ich wollte mir einen Skalpell holen oder irgendwie ein paar, weil die Dinger sind super zum Auspacken. Zum Auspacken, zum Controller rausmachen, irgendwas abmachen oder so. Da kommste mit Zangen und Schere nicht so gut hin.
Deswegen wollte ich mir schon wirklich lange mal einen Skalpell holen. Irgendwie sowas hier. Das ist doch wahrscheinlich alles Müll.
Guckt euch mal die ganzen Profi-Unboxing-Channels. Nee, Cuttermesser ist dafür auch nicht so gut. Skalpell, das ist halt ultra scharf. Du kannst einfach in die Hand nehmen und damit ein Paket aufschneiden, ohne das draufdrücken zu müssen. Das ist super geil. Guckt euch mal die ganzen Unboxer an, die haben auch fast alles Skalpells.
Ihr werdet einfach geschrieben und du merkst nichts. Ja, wir hatten es von Schweizer Mobilfunkverträgen vorher. Machete.
Obwohl wir gerade dabei sind. Was ich auch noch bräuchte ist, allerdings nicht einfach so eine Pinzette, nicht so eine random Pinzette, sondern ich glaube Knippex macht so Dinger.
Sondern ich will so eine Reverse Pinzette. Sowas, sowas hier. Allerdings mit einem ordentlichen Griff.
Skalpell und Pinzette. Sowas hier, so eine Kreuz-Kreuz-Pinzette heißt das. Kreuz-Pinzette. Nicht Kreuz. Kreuz-Pinzette.
Weil das ist, wenn man Kleinkramen macht, wenn man irgendwelche Sachen lötet und muss was festhalten, ist das wirklich nützlich. Das Problem mit normalen Pinzetten ist, du musst permanent draufdrücken und dementsprechend zittert man ein bisschen.
Das sieht man zwar nicht unbedingt, aber wenn man wirklich ganz klein Scheiß löten muss, so zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht ob ich den Kram hier noch irgendwo habe. Ja, zum Beispiel, so ungefähr auf dieser Größenebene.
Ungefähr. Das ist machbar, noch ohne Lupe und, okay die Lupe ist nicht verkehrt, das ist aber noch machbar ohne Mikroskop und sowas. Man muss ja nicht übertrieben.
Was ist das denn? Meister, Messer? Genau, das holen wir zum Unboxen. Bestes Unboxing Tool.
Römisches Unboxing. Was es nicht alles gibt.
11 Monate Ice Freak, Dankeschön. Pogger Subscription, Dankeschön. So, nochmal kurz hier dazu zurück. Wenn man so Kleinkramen hier festhalten muss, dann ist eine Pinzette, die über Kreuz geht, wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Weil, wenn man sowas kleines festhält mit einer normalen Pinzette, also mit dem Finger kannst du sowas halt richtig kacke festhalten. Wenn man so einen Kleinkram festhält, ich mein das hier macht man eh besser mit Paste.
Ja, aber nehmen wir das hier mal als Beispiel. Und man nimmt so eine Pinzette, man nimmt eine normale Pinzette, dann musst du halt permanent die Pinzette zusammen drücken. Und dann zitterst du halt. Und Zittern ist auf dieser Größenordnung wirklich doof.
Und da sind solche Pinzetten sehr praktisch.
Ja, warum haben die so schlechte Bewertung?
Okay, es ist Müll, es ist Müll.
Du hast dir das Schwert bestellt. Exzellent. Ich mein, alternativ kann man sich für eine Knipex Pinzette auch einen 6er Set China Pinzetten kaufen.
Oh, jetzt wird es aber Luxus hier. Jetzt wird es aber Luxus. Jetzt wird es aber Luxus.
Das ist aber nicht mal was über Kreuz. Die wollen 65 Euro für 4 Pinzetten oder ist keine Kreuz Pinzette dabei? Ja, das sagt. Kann ich nicht gebrauchen.
Nee, das ist Mist. Oh Leute, ich muss ins Bett. 22 Euro.
Hol dir einfach ein iFixit ProTech Toolkit. Warum? Ich habe doch das meiste Werkzeug schon.
Oder was ist da alles dabei? iFixit, das klingt irgendwie so nach, kennt ihr noch diesen, wie hieß dieser Typ? Felix? Felix Fixit? Wie ist der Typ denn? Der Typ, Fixit Felix.
Kannst du eine Budget Lötstation empfehlen? Nee, leider nicht. Die einzige Lötstation, die ich je hatte, ist die hier.
Und die ist nicht Budget. Wieder. Die ist extrem nice, aber die ist nicht Budget.
Vor allem der Lötkolben ist nice. Der ist so richtig schön klein, handlich mit einem flexiblen Kabel. Exzellent. Ach guck mal, ist da ein Skalpell dabei?
Und ein Kreuz über Kreuz. Das ist gar nicht mal so übel. Und für jeden Mist irgendwie ein Ding drin. Taugt sowas was? Ich kenne die nicht. Taugt das was? Nein, kenne ich echt nicht.
Wirklich nicht? Habe ich noch nie gehört?
Okay, cool. Machen alle möglichen Leute auf YouTube Werbung für? Ja gut, ich gucke ja kaum YouTube im deutschsprachigen Raum. Und auch international habe ich es noch nicht gesehen, obwohl ich einige Werkzeugchannels abonniert habe.
Okay. Alles klar, Leute. Ich muss wirklich jetzt ins Bett. Ich muss morgen wieder früh aufstehen. Wir sehen uns morgen. Vielleicht. Mal gucken. Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. Schlaf gut, Chat.
Exzellent. Exquisite Q-Chat. Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.